oh
okay
so hopefully
up and running and people are seeing
we shall see
ah
just downloaded the book that's
wonderful pirates
hope you like it oh hi
cara i know you've read it already
i know kara's read it i know carowinds
read it
um not sure who else in the chat
may have
sexy as ever thank you very much like
i'm i am
like the mic is blocking this a little
bit but i
am i am doused in uh in rainbow
uh basically everywhere except the nails
i like i've gone the last couple of days
meaning to reapply
these nails this is the only one that's
still got color on it and i just
haven't gotten to it um
so yeah
um happy pride like hold on let me give
you a better look at the
because i'm actually super proud of this
uh of this eye shadow this this this was
a gamble
this was a gamble and it uh and it took
a bit of work
but uh i'm quite happy with with how
that turned out
uh so give you a better look at that but
yes happy pride and
also the book launch i
swear i actually did not um
sync it up uh purposefully
i i set the date just thinking like i'm
pretty sure i'll have my crap sorted by
then and
it'll be ready um but
um and then realizing later oh right
that's the start of
pride um
oh well happy birthday ms wicked wolf
happy 24th
oh god you're so young
you babies
ah hope you're having a great day it's
it's
it's been pretty good i've had a more
relaxed day
today i need to which means i need to
dedicate
tomorrow as a more intense uh work day
but um yeah
yeah it's been it's been pretty nice so
um
a little bit about the book there should
be um
links in the description so what is
currently available
is the book is available in an e-book
edition
either with or without the illustrations
um
which that's an option because i i came
to understand that some people really
find a lot of trouble
um with illustrations in e-readers and i
figured some might just want the option
to not bother with them at all
and then there are currently two
paperback editions
there hold on
there is the mass market um
which is the less expensive of the two
which is you know kind of
the you know your smaller paperback size
like sort of the classic you'd pick it
up at the airport kind of thing
and then there is the larger illustrated
edition
now the um the
paperback illustrated is not in color
it the um the illustrations are
monochrome in this uh trying to find a
decent
uh example here
so like there you go
um so do be aware of that if you want
full color
print edition it's gonna be a little bit
more time
because that's gonna end up being the
hard cover
that is gonna be full color it is gonna
be the most expensive edition of the
book
um and i hope to have that sorted within
the next week
but it the thing is i only have so much
direct control over these things
because the um the services that i'm
using to put these editions together
have to go through their own checks on
these things and
um i don't have control over how long
that takes or whether or not it comes
back with more notes or what have you
because a lot of it's
semi-automated but it still isn't on a
on a really tight timer so um
somebody had asked at one point um
which edition gave me the best residuals
um and ultimately it is going to be the
hardcover um
but like i don't want people to get too
hung up on
that idea get the edition that that you
want
uh what's probably going to get me the
least is the um
is the paperback with no uh
illustrations gets me the least but
again
i don't i would advise you not to make
your purchasing
choices based off that but i i know some
people were asking
gonna get the larger version my 21st
birthday has made me rich
so i have no excuse uh not to get it oh
well
well just don't blow your your funds
before then
but it's uh yeah it's live
which is crazy actually it's funny just
just to sort of illustrate the point
again about how little direct control
i have over these things the
two paperback editions available through
amazon
actually went live yesterday
um i didn't announce that because the
ebook wasn't gonna go live until today
so the the reason that happened is when
i
you know when everything was finalized
and i'm like yes please publish
on amazon you know it says it can take
anywhere from 12 to 72 hours for it to
go live so i did it
early in case it took on the longer end
it took on the shorter end and so those
were actually live a little
sooner than they were than they were
supposed to be
oh and the other thing that i should
mention
is if you want to get um
the um
illustrated monochrome
and support your local businesses this
is currently available through your
local bookstore and or library
they can get a hold of this um but
uh right now i don't have i'm gonna wait
and see
what sales numbers on the amazon
editions are like but i don't currently
have this available
um for the distribution to things like
um like bookstores or libraries uh
the hardcover will be though uh once
it's available that will also be
available
through your local um bookstores and
libraries support your local
businesses and public services
any word on international copies they
should be available um
i've it's hard for me to know because
it's hard for me to check
but i have authorized amazon and also
ingram
um to make them available
internationally now
exactly how readily
um you know it's going to be available
or how easily i don't know
it should be like i know my earlier
books were available at least for amazon
were available internationally
um because i would actually get um you
know i have the report data
you know saying when it was paid for
with
australian dollars or euros or japanese
yen or what have you so
um i would imagine they should be uh how
was your second shot was fine
actually um my arm is feeling mostly
recovered at this point i was just
sort of like a little tired a little
fatigued um
it didn't hit me that hard i i had a
couple friends who that second shot
knocked him on their ass and that that
did not happen to me
uh i can't wait especially because my
friend aliyah is doing the audiobook oh
oh sir jedi i did not realize you knew
her
oh that's that's fantastic i've
i'm almost done editing chapter one um
and i've gotten
i think i've she's gotten
um back to me up through chapter eight
and i'm almost done editing chapter one
so i
do not have a time frame on when the
audiobook will be available
um we're doing it in this kind of
piecemeal chapter by chapter way because
i
i can't afford to pay for
the reading of the entire audiobook up
front uh i don't have
the funds to do that but doing it um a
little bit at a time
you know gives me time to get into the
next month collect my funds from
patreon from youtube from tick tock from
wherever
for the month and then you know get some
more done
um have you ever gone skinny dipping
before
yes yes i have
um a couple of times
uh never like in a
lake or anything i've gone skinny
dipping in like
um a hot tub or you know
somebody's private pool um that i've
done
uh
oh oh breathing nerd dumb ooh i love the
name
you get a heart for the super chat
that's a reminder
um people who uh donate through the
super chat
they get hearts as a sign of my uh
appreciation and it also guarantees that
i will see your comment i try and keep
up with the chat
as best as i can otherwise um but this
does guarantee that i will see
and read your comment um congratulations
vera
no one has earned this more than you you
are so passionate loving everyone
appreciates you i'm ordering the book
tomorrow oh
thank you thank you very much breathing
nerddam i really appreciate that
it's oh
this has been a long time coming
uh when i think about how long i've been
working on this it's
almost um depressing
um have you seen the new samsung
sam thing it looks like elita battle
angel i'm assuming that's like a
commercial
or some sort of promotional campaign uh
no i haven't
uh how much for a jock not what is a
jock
nod like i i know i know when ben
donates like he
he gets a curt nod because a heart is
too much of a show of affection for
for him i don't i'm not sure what a jock
knot is the jock no the other way around
is it the
is is it the that one
uh i don't know it's a great achievement
thank you
like it's it's in some ways
it's hard for me to like appreciate how
much has gone into it because
um you know i couldn't get
a um a publisher to take it and i had to
self-publish
and i try and remind myself that does
not
diminish the work but you know you
there's little
voices in the back your head uh
first off happy pride thank you very
much um
you beautiful being you second have you
seen
watched etc anything um that is just
fun like a b movie um
trying to remember the last well the
last thing it's not a b movie but the
last thing i watched that
i like i'm not even gonna bother doing a
review on it was
um i watched uh remember the titans
which i'd never seen before and uh but
liz had and she wanted
me to watch it with her and that was
that was actually um
pretty good i i enjoyed that i mean like
two thousands ish denzel washington
giving
uh very commanding instructions yeah
yeah i um um
i i get the appeal of that
um but that was pretty good i i enjoyed
that
um jock nods are not recognized by
british greeting protocol
also happy pride month thank you for the
clarification on that ben
thank you kindly hmm
okay what i would qualify as b-movie
entertainment
that i've started taking it so if you
follow me on twitter you might have seen
me tweet about this
so um
i have been trying for
a month or more now
to play the last of us the original
it's very slow going partly because
i'm just like i'm so out of practice
with third person games
especially ones where i have control of
the camera i get motion sick really easy
and like when i gamed more regularly i
kind of built up a certain degree of
tolerance to it
but at this point i'm so out of practice
um controlling the camera
that no matter what camera control
system
i come up with it no it never feels
natural and at some point
i'm gonna forget which way moving the
stick moves the camera and it's gonna
move the opposite of the way i expect it
to
and i'm gonna get nauseous um it's made
it really
hard to appreciate and get and get
through
and so i took a break from that too
to try out metal gear rising revengeance
which is the stupidest
goddamn thing i have ever
seen or played and i mean that as the
highest possible compliment
it is bananas this thing it
is absurd and so idiotic and i am
loving it so far i'm only about an hour
into it but i
am loving it it's
so dumb it is so stupid
it's amazing like i can't i have a hard
time thinking of too many other things
that have the guts to be this boldly
stupid if you've never played so
i suspect most people who are gamers
have at least heard of metal gear solid
and like have a sense of those they're
they're stealth
kind of espionage convoluted stories a
little bit silly but it takes itself
pretty seriously
okay so metal gear rising revengeance is
set in that world
in that universe but it wasn't made by
hideo kojima who makes the made series
it was made by platinum games who are
the people who made stuff like bayonetta
and they
stripped out the taking this stuff
seriously
and dedicating dozens of minutes on end
to serious philosophical
conversations aspect of it which just
makes the stupid elements of it
all the stupider and the gameplay feeds
directly
into that it is one of the most
ridiculously over the top things i have
ever played and i kind of love it
it it starts with the kind of splash
that i don't know if it can maintain but
oh
dang did it open insanely
made me very happy and it was kind of
what i needed because
you know um to
to um quote
uh yahtzee crochet uh cyborg ninja flip
outs
beats dirty depressing people getting
their crap ruined
oh i didn't see that elfie was in the
chat hi alfie
elfie the cartoonist is one of the
illustrators
of the novel i actually i think did the
most illustrations
of the three illustrators i worked with
um
it's amazing that the book is out
although i'm gonna miss doing
illustrations for you
uh you are really good at explaining
what you want which has been super fun
thank you for letting me contribute
thank you so much for working with me
and like look
i have i have other
future projects set in this world and
if the if the book does well enough
when i get to more i will probably keep
them still being illustrated if like the
illustrated editions
sell the least i might drop that as a
conceit
but if i keep it you will definitely be
hearing from me
so don't you worry about that
when will you watch return to oz when
you pay me ms wicked wolf
pay me and i will watch it
remember great fantasy takes time uh
look at people like tolkien and
martin uh took and take forever to
finish books great fantasy takes a while
and it's worth the wait well
i i hope it's worth the wait
that's that's the thing i can only hope
that
um my sinking this much dang time into
it
uh was actually worth it
uh motion sickness sucks when gaming i
had to stop playing half-life
can play fortnite without getting sick
but watching my nephews play makes me
sick
yeah i can't watch other people play
games very much
and really anything where i have control
of the camera
um is is probably going to get me sick
at some point because like i said i
i would say
i i've been gaming so sporadically since
round about oh
2000 or 9
that like i've just gotten out of the
habit of like being good at working the
camera
and so it never feels natural and i can
never get it to behave quite the way i
wanted to so the more
a game requires me to be the one working
the camera
and it doesn't have a good reliable um
thing on it which is another thing i'm
appreciating about metal gear rising
revengeance the the camera only requires
the occasional nudge from me last of us
i i have to be in total control of that
thing um
and it's it's not it's not treating me
nice
uh congrats right now i'm envisioning
the leisure ship from thor
ragnarok when uh bruce hit the big
button
fireworks went off jeff goldblum's high
[ __ ] voice saying it's your birthday
that's a fun movie anything it'll be a
bit of a been a bit of a long day so i
won't be around long but congrats on the
book oh thank you randomness
well thank you for stopping in all the
same i i really appreciate that
all right let me just catch up on
the chat oh the book is available
internationally via kindle amazon
unlimited
reading it now here in ireland oh well
good
that's that's reassuring because like i
i knew that
should have been the case but like
i i also know my luck so
wait until you get to the final boss an
episode of dragon ball z where the
villain is hulk hogan
yelling about right wing politics um
being great and body slamming anyone who
disagrees i see you also
watch zero punctuation yes i i recognize
that turn of phrase about it
you said you enjoyed beau burnham have
you watched inside yet i have not
i like i thought i was going to watch
that today
but i didn't get to it so maybe
later i don't know i'm going to shoot a
video after the stream's over
and then depending on what time it is
maybe i'll watch
after that i'm not i'm not sure though
random comic fact deadpool has a
daughter named eleanor
who is a different version uh who has a
different version of his healing factor
where if she dies her body reverts back
to when her power first manifested
ha
odd it's an interesting twist on it
uh have you seen cruella yet
no because i refuse to pay 30 bucks and
i don't pirate
so until it becomes free
uh to watch on disney plus i won't be
watching it by the time that happens
um no one's gonna care anymore so
yeah yeah i'm not um i'm not in any rush
uh do you know what's one thing i've
noticed in the oz sequels like return to
legend of and journey back to us
dorothy's original friends are always
sidelined for new ones
well that's true in the books too
i'm pretty sure like i think some of
them turn up again later but
the as the series went on it it becomes
about completely new characters
as it goes on as a snarky british man of
course
i watch yahtzee also he's gaming stu
bagful
yeah not actually that's that's a fair
comparison
yeah that works um
let's see
realize that i missed both specials so
once this is over i'm watching that wow
hope you enjoy it hope i enjoy it like
that's a new enough thing that when
um when i watch it i'll probably do a
review on the break room
uh
let me see something real quick
okay so
um i i debated whether to do this or not
but if people are up for it
i am willing in the spirit of this being
a
book launch um live stream
to read the first chapter of the book
um live on the stream
if people want that let's see what the
reaction is
uh got the cruella de vil song in my
head now
gradual crew gotta stop
don't need the bots flagging me
ah
oh okay
um okay all right people seem to be up
for that
so now first thing to keep in mind
is that there will be an audio book it
is not going to be read by me so don't
expect this to necessarily be a preview
of that
but um it'll give you a taste of what
the book is if you
were maybe not sure if it was something
for you
here we go dreams of fire
chapter one ferris hugged his midsection
and waited for the line to advance
the setting sun cast its pink hue across
his fellow travelers faces
as it descended behind the mountains the
other travelers ranged from
weather beaten to well-kept with the
latter doing their best not to rub
elmo's with the former
ferris was worse for wear his clothes
dirt and crusted and grass stained
from nearly a week of on-foot travel
lost the dagran river
if he'd stuck to the main road he'd have
gotten to this point days ago but the
fear of pursuit had kept him
on the more roundabout route
that vehicle over there is worth more
than your annual wage and i'm telling
you it would be safer outside the gate
with inside of the watchtower than in
that stable where any rabble can pry
parts off it
snapped a tall dark-skinned man and a
long bright green coat
he stood with his arms crossed trying to
intimidate the visibly unimpressed head
of the watch
who is tapping their foot while waiting
for him to finish his rant
sir they said straightening their brown
leather coat for emphasis
perhaps you've not bunked down for the
night in an outpost like this before
look around they paused and waited for
the man to actually look around which
took a few moments before he
begrudgingly did so
see all these walls these little
buildings
in here they asked evenly notice
anything
listening in ferris couldn't help but
look around
they had built the outpost for space
efficiency with a series of crate-like
buildings within its 20-foot
high walls watch towers were spaced
evenly along the walls and
one of the members of the watch was
lighting torches and lamps
it needs a coat of paint and proper
lights smug the man
it's wood said the head of the watch
sharply no metal nothing
running on lightning cages no combustion
motors
we're in the middle of the wild world
and your motor carriage
in out in the open all night will
attract
the fae the man's shoulders slumped
he raised a hand and opened his mouth
but the head of the watch steamrolled
him before he could get a word in
moving along the road is one thing
they'd ignore that
and if the only danger were that they'd
break it down and bury the pieces i'd
frankly let it happen
they continued seemingly becoming a
little taller with each word
or perhaps the man in the green coat was
shrinking
but faye taking an interest in something
right at our door is a danger to every
man
woman gray and child in this outpost
so either drive it to the stables for
the night where it's out of sight or
i'll have the watch turn it on its side
and drag it
there ferris smiled as the man in the
greeting coat huffed impotently before
storming off out of the gate to retrieve
the vehicle
the line began moving forward as the
night's borders were
as the night's borders were handed
bedrolls and directed to the largest
building
to find a spot to sleep fair is tensed
as he inched closer and closer to the
front of the line
there was no reason for the watchman to
question his presence or appearance
it hadn't happened to anyone else so far
but at the back of his mind
ferris heard a hissing insistence that
he was about to be pulled aside
a bead of sweat dripped down his
forehead which he swiped at hastily
he reached the front and the watchman
didn't even look up from his board
number in your party um one
a bed roll was shoved against his chest
and it took a second for ferris to think
to take hold of it properly
and follow the others to the rest to the
rest house
inside it was practically empty aside
from the people
settling down in groups with their bed
rolls he scurried around a few clusters
headed toward the back and opened the
bedroll it was hardly luxury
accommodations
but it was a step up from sheltering
under a tree without covering because
he didn't think to grab a blanket when
he'd fled
he laid down and rested his head on a
thin pillow that he'd been given
smiling up at the ceiling dimly lit by a
few lanterns that dotted the walls
there was little doubt he'd sleep
sounder than he had in some time
he just hoped that the night would not
bring
another dream
the night was cold yet an oddly warm
breeze
rustled through the forest's thick
covering of leaves and branches
ferris ran his fingers through his sandy
hair brushing it out of his face as he
tilted his head back looking at the sky
the canopy above him parted like
curtains on some great stage at the
start of a play
the moon was a sliver in the sky and the
stars shone brighter than he'd ever seen
in his 17 years of life
after a few moments he dropped his head
above him came the creaking sound
of the parted trees closing back into
their impenetrable canopy
faced once more with the darkness of the
forest ferrous gripped the mane of his
mount
a large and powerful mare the stars that
had lit up the sky
did little to penetrate the leaves now
closed in above him
his straining eyes could only see
vaguely defined constantly shifting
shadows
yet the mare moved forward at a steady
and unbroken pace
somehow confident in her chosen path
ferris's legs wrapped around her bare
middle and he dreaded the thought of
falling off
he squinted in the darkness trying to
force the shadows around him to form
more defined shapes
this only made the shadows appear more
fluid than before
he swallowed hard as he felt anxiety
rising in his chest
he slowly turned his head from one side
to the other hoping to find some source
of light that might reassure him
that he wasn't completely lost and alone
a glimmer of a campfire
the first hint of mourning anything that
might penetrate the darkness even for a
second
unable to bring the murky surroundings
into focus his eyes drifted downward
and he couldn't help but notice a
strange quality of the mayor that had
eluded him up to now
as complete as the darkness around him
seemed
she seemed somehow even darker
and blacker overhead the branches
shifted against a slow
shifted again with a slow groaning creek
sounding like massive doors with hinges
that had never been oiled
a mist this low grown was the faint
fluttering
of wings when the canopy above him
cracked open again
the pinpricks of starlight caused the
damp trunks of the trees to glimmer in a
way that should have been comforting
indeed he would have expected to be
somehow reassuring
but it wasn't not even a little bit
it was mocking him it took a little
while before he noticed that the mayor
had quickened her pace
having been too busy focusing on the
solidifying scene around him
and trying to anticipate what might
happen next without
panicking at the possibilities as the
sensation of the mayor's
steady trot sank in he looked down at
her
at her once more her coat
was impenetrable to the eye even
in the soft glow created by the thin
beams of light
glint glinting dancing on the lingering
raindrops clinging to the tree trunks
and she was just as ill-defined now
as she had been in the near-total
darkness
the mayor's coat had no shine no
clear point where she ended and the
night began
the light seemed to simply collapse
into her as his breath hastened
from the fear crawling into his throat
ferris tried recalling
how he came by this mystifying black
mare
to his bewilderment he could not find a
firm memory of her before the journey
they were on at this very moment
he soon realized he could not remember
where they were going or where they had
come from
he could not recall any memory of why he
was in the forest at such a time of
night
most disconcerting of all none of these
holes in his memory had struck him as
out of place until just then
this thought process was interrupted by
a sudden jolt as the mayor broke into a
full gallop
the flutter of wings around ferris
became louder and he heard a
high-pitched chattering that seemed at
once
to be in the distance yet also inside
his head
he gripped the mayor's mane so tightly
his hands started to tremble
the path on which they rode narrowed as
the tree's branches began to stretch
reaching out to claw at ferris gnarled
wooden limbs
shed their leaves as they reached for
him scratching across his arms and his
shoulders
the pointed tip of one branch cut across
his face and he felt the warm trickle of
blood run down his cheek
and follow his jawline before dripping
off his chin
the drops of blood fell into the mayor's
coat where they vanished
consumed by the darkness of the
galloping beast beneath him
farris held on to the mayor's mane like
it was his only lifeline
despite a growing sense of unease about
his mount the beast hooves thundered as
they
hit the ground and the air rushing past
his head should have been deafening but
instead
the cacophony of noise was fading into
the background becoming a little more
than a distant hum
his ears instead rang with sounds that
should have been too quiet to detect the
sounds
of delicate wings flying against the
wind a gentle thud caused by something
leaping from tree to tree
incessant high-pitched chattering soon
dominated his hearing
as the noise gathered strength it took
on the qualities of a laugh
but not a laugh like anything he had
heard before rather some
strange mockery of laughter it sounded
like an imitation
performed by something that had never
laughed before
ferris tucked in close to his mount
pressing his body down
tightly against the back and neck of the
mare the beast felt cold as he brought
him
more of his body closer it was not a
sense of cold that would have come from
the running animal itself being freezing
instead it was as though his own body's
heat
was being drained from him by the black
void of a horse on which he rode
his energy and strength were beginning
to slip away when a howling cackle
cut through the air behind him something
landed on his back
roughly nearly knocking him off the mare
diminutive hands gripped at ferris's
shoulders while a pair of small feet
pressed against the small of his back
sharp
thorny toes dug in and held firm while
spiked fingers raked
slowly down either side of his spine
tearing away the skin
and replacing it with searing pain
through it all the thing upon his back
cackled unnaturally
in his ear ferris tried to shake the
creature off but the thorns held fast
even as the fingers dragged through more
of his flesh he threw his head back to
scream
but his lungs failed him and only a weak
whisper passed his lips
he silently prayed to lose consciousness
but every passing second only heightened
the painful sensation
a flash of light banished the dark
before settling into a less
intensely bright pulse like a heartbeat
the trees
retreated from the flash and the path
widened
everything lit as if the sun was among
the trees
except for one thing the mayor's coat
swallowed up the light that was now
illuminating the forest
however blazing licks of fire had
replaced the thick
tufts of mane beneath his grasp
the flames wrapped around the young
man's wrists and fingers and held them
fast
his skin blistered and cracked the flesh
charred and blackened like a piece of
meat thrown directly into an opening
flame
except this meat felt every lick of heat
and every new blister ferris struggled
to
and struggled to free his hands from the
agony of the fire
but the flames held him as tightly as
iron shackles he looked around in panic
soon his eyes locked onto the head of
the mare the labored breath from the
mayor's nostrils made the air
bend and waver with its heat and a newly
formed twist
of blackness ending in a pointed spike
protruded from its forehead
without any break from its thundering
stride the mare turned its head to one
side
until its eye met with ferrises
the beast's iris was the same bottomless
pit of blackness
as her coat except for a single point
in the center the point was infinitely
small
and would have been undetectable had it
not been made of the
purest white light this point of light
burned its way
into his very being even more harshly
than the fire of the mane burned his
flesh
by now the skin on his hands had begun
to shrivel and curl back from the heat
peeling away exposing the muscle and
bone
which had also begun to char the pain
was unbearable
yet he found himself locked in place by
that single point of light in the
mayor's eye
something was buried beneath the
embodiment of rage and pain on which he
rode
and it was reaching out the mayor's eye
blinked and the light
was gone as faris awoke
he opened his eyes to a sideways world
he was lying on his right side curled up
on his makeshift bed
his forehead drenched in sweat the
shaved logs that formed the resting
house walls
replaced the sinister trees of his dream
the blazing light of the mayor's
fiery mane gave way to the dull flicker
of candles at the far end of the room
the otherworldly creature was already
fading from his mind
the malevolent chattering and fluttering
of wings were replaced with gentle
snoring
and the shuffle of blankets as others
slept on similar mats
spread throughout the room everything
had changed
yet the burning pain in his hands
remained faris looked at his hands
they were not blistering or peeling as
they had been in his dream
but the pain and the heat were worse
than ever
as he pushed against the floor to get to
his feet there was a crackling sound
where he placed his hands
when he pulled them away he saw the
floor blackened and
scorched where he touched it clenching
his left wrist as tightly as possible
ferris worked his way steadily across
the room he silently cursed himself
and cursed himself for taking a spot so
far away from the exit
if he'd only looked behind himself and
seen the dozens of people behind him
he might have thought better of it but
it was too late now
and winding his way among the densely
packed forms
strewn about it in a way that left no
direct path out
half the lanterns have been allowed to
burn out and the few left casts
flickering shadows
so the thick beams that held up the roof
took on a haunting quality similar to
the trees of his nightmare
appearing to bend and weave of their own
accord by the time
ferris was halfway across the room he
was sucking his breath in through his
teeth
and and was nearly doubled over
clutching his wrist
and the searing pain to his gut the heat
was beginning to rise in his right hand
as well the pain came in waves and each
time
it eased and each time it eased even a
little
he looked to the lanterns that stood on
either side of the double doors to the
outside
with only a few dozen feet to go the
burning surged up his arm
he gasped and fell to his knees as sweat
dripped into his eyes
he was ready to give up to let it all
flow out of him
when the scent of perfume wafted up and
caught his nose
and shot the reminder that he was not
the only life in the room directly into
his brain
he gritted his teeth and tried to stand
holding his left hand to his chest
he reached his right to the ground to
steady himself through the veil of
searing pain
he did not see the bare shoulder of
another traveler poking out from under a
blanket
his hand grazed the exposed flesh
a piercing scream rang out and filled
the room
as a woman threw back her blanket and
cradled the burnt and blistering flesh
of her shoulder shadowy figures sat
bolt up across the room some rising to
their feet while others scooted away or
huddled together
the sounds of confusion and fear echoed
off the walls like a harmony to the
woman's screams
another woman nearby lunged toward her
pushing ferris out of the way
she didn't realize he'd caused it and
the fear on the pit of his stomach told
him
that would only be the case for a few
seconds he
bolted to the double doors holding both
hands tightly against his stomach
puffs of smoke rose as his shirt began
to smolder from the heat
he left over several forms still on the
ground and felt a rush of air as someone
reached for him and missed by inches as
he reached the doors he aimed his
shoulder at the crack between them
burst out into the moonlight and open
air
he stumbled to the center of the
courtyard as the burning sensation
spread up both his arms and began to
cross over into his chest
his vision grew foggy he looked all
around
turning a complete circle in the haze of
pain clouding his memory of where the
main gate was
there had been a small shed-like
structure near it but there were at
least
four of those in the dim glow of
moonlight everything blurred together
and a haze of growing pain
behind him screams echoed out of the
resting hall
he winced trying desperately to block
the sound out
watchmen peered into the courtyard from
their post along the wall
a voice rang out from the hall's open
door why is he running
ferris looked back at the orange glow
coming from the doorway and saw several
silhouettes emerge
one of them was pointing at him he shot
his eyes around frantically hunting for
the exit
and and be prepared to bolt
in a random direction rather than stay
in place
he clutched his hand to his chest
wincing and sweating
a shadowy figure near one of the sheds
became lit
by an actively by an app
sorry became lit by an activated shock
rod
sparks accompanied by the sharp clicking
of electricity arcing between the rods
prongs
the fire that was raging just beneath
the skin of his arm
was spreading had had spread inward
meeting in the center of his body and
intensified
sorry just
sorry just trying to fix something here
there we go
ah stupid thing completely lost the flow
now
uh he knew from experience that he
wasn't far away from collapsing
he whipped his head around and his eyes
finally focused on the twin
twin lamps marking the gate as figures
closed in on him from behind he gathered
every ounce of energy he had left and
propelled himself to his escape
he heard shouts from behind him and he
did not dare look back
stop that boy shock rods flickered to
life from all sides
and closed in as ferris forced himself
to move forward with everything he had
if he could get outside he would not be
followed not at night
not if he made for the tree line the
heavy double doors reached
up the wall reached up the walls full
height barred with a thick block of wood
across them
but next to it was a smaller door the
size of a normal house front entrance
meant for single travelers and closed
with a simple wooden bolt
ferrous couldn't slow down enough to
keep from slamming his shoulder against
the sturdy door
the door didn't budge from the impact
and the clicking of the shock rods was
closing in all around
ferris leaned a hand on the door for
support while he pulled back the locking
bolt
the wood smoked and crackled under his
touch
once the bolt was free ferrous opened
pulled the door open and flung
himself out into the open air a jolt of
searing heat
surged in his chest and he fell to his
knees in the dirt
stop don't go out there leave me
alone farris shouted pushing himself off
the bare ground
at first he stuck to the road to put as
much distance between himself and the
outpost
as he could before veering into the long
grass that would
that would slow him down the moon bathed
the road but it all blurred together as
he fought to hold back the heat
radiating from his hands
it was like trying to hold back a thin
door against an incoming tide
his stride slowed as another wave of
heat shot up his arms to his chest
began to creep into his throat there was
a loud crack from behind him
and a white electric bolt soared over
his shoulder and singed the ground on
the uneven road ahead of him
now clearly unsafe on the open road
ferris veered off
and made for the miles of thick woods
that separated the road from the
mountains
dashing through the tall grass that
buffeted the road
he could make out the thick trunks and
high branches of the everwood there was
another crack of noise from behind
stupid thing sorry
there was another crack of noise from
behind him but this time
the bolt only flew into the night sky
glancing back at the outpost one last
time
ferris could make out several figures
wrestling a bolt rifle from the hands
of whoever had been firing the shots
none of them made any moves to follow
him
he tumbled over the waist high stone
wall that bordered the tree line
and floundered into the darkness of the
forest it seemed to him
he only made it a few steps into the
woods before collapsing to his knees
and among a cluster of ferns however one
panicked glance back revealed he'd gone
deep enough into the forest
the light from the outpost beacon
torches could not be seen
he tried to get his feet under him but
promptly fell to his knees once more
ferris stopped fighting the burning from
within and finally let it flow
flames erupted in the air around him
swirling and coalescing into a whirlpool
searing heat expelled itself from his
fingertips
the last of his energy drained with the
fire and the blazing flickers dispersed
he went limp and collapsed
there we go
that that went on for a little longer uh
than i thought it would
but i hope people enjoyed
um oh james thank you very much
you get a heart thanks for reading to us
oh you're very welcome
uh little self-indulgent but
um glad uh
i hope folks liked it uh
the chat uh is now flying past me
my gosh i honest to goodness
cannot keep up with that well thank you
i i'm gonna take this as uh
as positive feedback
do you use home chef miss wicked wolf
you've asked me that kind of thing
before i don't use anything like that
you know that
any reason you won't be reading the
audiobook um
two reasons um one
time uh the other paranoia
so um
[Music]
like having the time to keep up my
regular video schedule
of shooting and editing and the
podcasting and everything else
um and trying to get the audiobook done
in a reasonable amount of time
i'm not sure that's in the cards for me
being able
to um
to handle that but the other thing is
i am paranoid about
my skill as a reader
and additionally about the uh
whether or not my audio setup is truly
um professional grade
i like to think it is but i
i have a deep paranoia of
um sinking a lot of time
into you know doing the reading and then
um getting in to try and try and edit it
and realize it just
sounds like garbage um
or that you know trying to do audio
engineering on it i can only get it to
sound so good
and i re for this like here's the thing
my next major um
project is doing an audiobook version of
my first book which was skirting gender
that one i am going to read myself
because that's my own story
like i would feel really weird hearing
anybody else
read that um so i'm gonna have to suck
it up and figure it out for that
but part of the other thing is is that
the
um the book was funded by the
kickstarter which to me
puts a lot more
pressure on getting it done timely and
at the highest professional grade
whereas me updating and um
doing a reading for skirting gender
you know that i'm not going to have any
sense of a deadline on that
i i i want to get it done this year but
that's not something where i'm going to
feel like i'm
letting um a bunch of people who have
already given me money down
um because of how long it's taking so
just the pressure involved in knowing
that the entire project was kick-started
that that kind of
put me in a position where i wasn't
comfortable being the one doing the
audio book
now that said like the audiobook was
also a stretch goal
so um if
um if i hadn't hit the stretch goal for
the kickstarter to do an audio book
that's not to say that there never would
have been one available
but it probably would have been me doing
it and it would have and it would be
happening
way late like it would probably be next
year
um for that so um
yeah that's that's sort of the
excuse me confluence of uh of reasons
why um why that
why i'm not the one doing the audiobook
um
it's not easy reading one's own work
well done thank you and like even as i'm
reading i'm like oh god some of these
sentences still don't scan
so yes it's you know
i am always i'm always gonna find
something that i'm like ah
freaking hell about the
about this book like i i know that um
skirting gender is a beautiful pun by
the way i wish i could take full credit
for that
so i stole that title um
from a podcasting friend of mine uh
uh professor allen middleton who
podcasts
um in a couple of places on the
on the relatively geeky network which is
uh him
and his uh offspring m uh
who is lovely also um and also they both
do
darkness to light which is a very
occasional podcast that i love
but he was the one who like i think in
in
replying to a piece of feedback i'd
written
on to one of their episodes used the
term skirting gender and i just i
stole it
uh professor allen's fun he really is
carol and he's he's great um the john
purdue season 8 blu-ray set came out in
the us today looking forward to watching
behind behind the sofas and all the
other awesome special features do you
own any of these sets
i don't the thing is i'm not really i'm
not a completionist
anymore there was a there was a point in
my life when
i was a bit more of a completionist
um but like i'm just not now like i do
eventually want to see
all of the classic stuff but i don't
feel the need to own it
um so yeah
uh all fair reasons
though you have a great voice for it but
i can understand time budgeting and tech
issues well
i'm glad it's understandable like i'm
look i'm a performer i'm narcissistic
and i'm
cocky about my own ability so i like to
think i could read it well
it's you know it's doubts about the
equipment in my abilities as a
as an audio editor and my ability to do
it in any kind of a timely manner
is the issue um
i showed a friend one of my audio dramas
and she had the exact reaction
i wanted for the main character i hate
that i'm starting to like her
[Laughter]
on my to-do list uh of
um discord yes thank you carowind i will
get right to that in a second
uh on my to-do list is an audio drama
that i want to do
where like because of the premise of it
and uh the the diegetic
reason for everything being recorded
it's not gonna matter if the audio
quality isn't
the best in the world um so
i've kind of gotten out uh even when i
ever get around to that but yes
discord uh which is your reminder that
the
um council
council of geeks discord is a patreon
exclusive perk
and there is a channel there to drop
questions which is the one other way
besides doing super chats to guarantee
that i will check out your comments and
questions so
okay so the first question um
is uh from someone who actually had read
the book
and said can you explain what the
treshan are i got the gist
uh from the book well i wasn't sure if
they were from real mythology the
treshin
are my one and only original
fey species um all of the other
uh fey creatures that show up are
um slightly tweaked in most cases but
are
versions of things that exist in
folklore somewhere
the trashion are the one major exception
those
those are my creation um
i did a whole video on this um as part
of the uh the author diaries over in the
break room of geeks so you can go there
for a lot more detail
but long story short i actually came up
with them early
in my formulating the idea for the story
and i always liked them and i initially
tried to come up with a lot more
original um species but i didn't like
any of the other
ideas i had and so eventually i just
thought well i'll just i'll
i'll have it be fade creatures plus my
one original thing
um because i like them too much to ditch
them
as as a as a thing um and like in terms
of
what they are and how it feeds into
things i kind of needed it to be an
original thing because for what i wanted
to do
there wasn't really an analog like the
closest thing
might have been changelings but that
would have been a stretch
um for what they are and sort of how
they're utilized and what their deal is
um uh one of those nights
when i need sleep and can't stay up have
fun oh so this was uh
uh aong has saying that they wouldn't
make it but question congrats on the
brook
and maybe this will be covered already
but as a writer which authors have been
your biggest inspiration
or perhaps better currently are um
i can tell you some of my favorite
writers are i don't know how much of an
inspiration they are because i
i try really hard not to um
write like other people if i can help it
i mean i prob for this book anyway i
probably took more
narrative inspiration from
final fantasy vi and the anime vision of
escaflowne
um than from any of the authors i like
um but i mean authors that i really
enjoyed would include
neil gaiman douglas adams i read a lot
of ari salvatore
uh when i was younger that probably had
an influence in terms of
uh sort of writing in a more cinematic
vein
uh because i'm not the mo i'm not the
most literary uh
of writers um
if that makes sense uh also standard
writer question are you a plotter or a
pantser
i am a general plotter like i need to i
need to know where
i'm going i i definitely need to know
what the end is going to be if i don't
know what the end is going to be i'll
never get there
um but i i do not outline
i i have a general sense of what the
major beats i want to be sure to hit are
but i don't figure out how those beats
connect and how i get from a to b to c
to d um before i start writing i'll just
start writing and know okay at some
point i need to end up here
let's let's try and nudge the story and
the characters so we get there and then
we'll
work on getting to the next point but i
don't do detailed outlines
um it's it's it's bullet points at most
um let's see haven't read the book yet
but i want to well
i hope you enjoy it when you do what's
your favorite sp face species or
folk tale ooh um
i don't know i'm
the thing is my fascination with the fey
has less to do with like specific
stories about them than just the
vibe and the feel of those kinds of
stories it's a very
it's very much an atmosphere thing for
me if that makes sense
and less about like really latching on
to
specific stories um and there are some
things that just sort of
pop up as as elements or feels
in these stories that just kind of
fascinate me
without necessarily gripping me as
narratives
would you say your book has an age of
people you're writing for like a
demographic i didn't write it for a
specific demographic in mind
having had it read by people who have a
good sense of this
um i would put it at middle school and
up
um as appropriate again it's not
necessarily
aimed at like the a younger or a young
adult
audience i'd like to think it would
appeal to them so like i don't have a
target but it is certainly appropriate
for middle schooling up
or like i'd let i'd let my my kid
read it and she'll she'll be 10 in a few
months
um i don't know if she'll want to read
it but
um like that's that's sort of what i'd
say i mean like
you you might have gotten a sense from
the chapter that i read that like there
are some
frightening elements there are some
there's some dangers and some harm that
that is gonna come to characters but you
know
uh so
i'm gonna hop back into the chat and uh
try and wrap it up because i i do have
some other stuff i want to do and i
definitely appreciate everyone who
turned out
honestly there's so much faith to choose
from in mythology
that you never need to make your face
stuff up wholesale
like true but i had a really specific
thing that i wanted to do with
detression that
like i said there just wasn't there
wasn't an existing faith that i could
find
that like i would have had to modify
them so much that i'm like
at that point i i would just feel like i
was being disrespectful
to the original folklore and i was
better off just having my original thing
i'm watching this in return to oz at the
same time you don't know what you're
missing oh no i've seen the movie i know
exactly what i'm missing
congratulations and salutations thank
you emily
um just trying to catch up real quick
speaking of faith folklore have you ever
seen brian fraud's fairy oracle deck i
have not i have
like some of his books um but no i don't
have that
i do know who brian proud is though oh
that's good stuff
congrats again on your book launch and
happy pride thank you pirates
um my reading is what's happening to
ferris is a metaphor
for what your feelings about hell bent
would like to deal with
uh interesting reading i'll point out
i've been working on this a hell of a
lot longer than hell bent has been a
thing that exists so
i mean in recent years the 11th doctor
has gone down in my rankings quite a bit
but the other day i realized he's my
favorite doctor
when i'm stoned
interesting perspective uh will you
watch in the heights
maybe if i have time if i feel like it
and or if somebody pays me um i am i am
going to wrap it up for the night
um so thank you uh
everybody for tuning in um
thank you for the support and the fact
that i've been
uh sinking as much
time into this as i have
like there's a part of me that that
worries you know
i should um
i should be working more on on the video
stuff
but you know having this
and being supported in taking the time
to do this
um really helps yes thank you carowind
twitch
tomorrow 10 30 a.m
uh still gonna be hearthstone and
hanging out um
because i still haven't gotten a new
computer i keep saying next time
like i don't know when the hell i'm
gonna get to it um but
yes i'll be on twitch on the council of
geeks twitch
channel tomorrow at 10 30 if you want to
see me there
and uh i hope everybody
has a lovely evening
hope you have a wonderful pride i really
hope that you remember
that you are beautiful you are valid
and you are loved because you
are the council and i only run the
meetings
and until next time this council is
adjourned
mckelvery